[Musique]
un parcours botanique a été inauguré ce
vendredi 2 juin au lazaret de la Grande
Chaloupe un voyage dans l'histoire de
l'engagisme et du peuplement avec un
parcours de visite complet autour de la
thématique du métissage végétal
alors le parcours botanique métissage
végétal c'est un parcours de visite qui
invite les publics à découvrir les
espèces végétales du Lazare et numéro 1
et du Lazare et numéro 2 donc à
découvrir les espèces dans leur
environnement et à découvrir les usages
qui sont faits de ces espèces végétales
les visiteurs peuvent découvrir des
espèces fruitières des espèces potagères
aromatiques ça peut être aussi des
arbres endémiques ça peut être on parle
également des espèces envahissantes donc
vraiment on a un panel très large
d'espaces végétal et on explique pour
chaque espèce leur histoire leurs
origines et leurs usages le Lazare et
lui emblématique de l'engagisme a été
ainsi de quarantaine pour des milliers
de travailleurs engagés durant le 19e
siècle jusqu'au début du 20e siècle
ces populations se sont côtoyées ont
échangé leurs connaissances savoir faire
et traditions notamment sur les plantes
et leurs usages vous voyez le lieu il
n'est pas anodin le lazaré qui est un
lieu hautement historique ou nous
engager sont venus de toutes parts de
l'océan Indien de Madagascar des Comores
de Chine et sont arrivés ces populations
avec leurs plantes des plantes
médicinales ou des plantes pour usage
cultuel et
ces gens sont venus avec leurs plantes
mais aujourd'hui c'est un patrimoine
culturel partagé par l'ensemble de la
population réunionnaise et tout le monde
s'est approprié ces plantes ce n'est
plus une plante d'une communauté ou
d'une autre c'est la plante des
Réunionnais et nous la partagerons nous
essayons de préserver tout ce patrimoine
ce parcours est accessible au public
porteur de handicap notamment déficient
visuel grâce à des podcasts disponibles
chez soi sur internet ou télécharger
depuis son téléphone directement au
lazaret
[Musique]